على كل حال سالنا الناس عدد سكان العالم
سيبلغ 8 مليارات نسمه هل انت متفائل
بمستقبل البشريه او متشائم ولماذا دعونا
نستمع لاجابات الناس من الاردن
[موسيقى]
على مر العصور في عندهم ابداعات وعندهم
اختراعات في حضارات سابقه وراح يكون اكيد
في انجازات القادمه فان شاء الله القادم
افضل يكون للبشريه كلها ان شاء الله كله
خير
تفضل 8 مليار 18 مليار ما في شيء بصير
ربنا كاتب له الخير يعني
تفاعل انه
يزيدوا البشريه ولو زادوا البشريه يعني مش
هياثر على الكره الارضيه يعني الي بنسمع
وانا بشوفه غلط لان الكوره فاضيه
بس في عمان اطلع عن طريق المطار بتلاقيها
فاضيه لا هذا الشيء التشاؤم والتفاؤل
صعب
يتكلموا فيها موضوع
السكان والتضعف الديموغرافيا هذا
متشائم يعني بالنسبه نحنا هسه احنا تمانيه
مليار وصلناهم اول شيء اقتصاد الدوله يلا
نكفي الموجودين
نعمل ولا موفرين شغل ولا شيء يلا الواحد
قادر يسكر يسلك حاله بالاكل الوضع الماديه
بالنسبه للغلاء البنزين غلاء المعيشه غلاء
كل شيء هو بصراحه شايف الامور زايد عن
حدها فاكثر كل الناس صار تضخم بالسكان كل
ما زاد عندك المصاريف فهذه بتاثر سلبيا
كبير بالنسبه الاقتصاد العالمي والمحلي